she has no idea what she just walked
into Kelly Rohrbach there's a whole
panel here yes those are those are
called the Dennis there Kelly Danna
yeah and they they drive who do you
think overdressed today now McLovin
Fritzi here that's a seat in here and
Pauli at the very end so if you were
just sizing this up of somebody who
looks like they gave some thought to
their wardrobe today uh Seaton but Otto
Polly Polly Polly wolly hooked up
because you look so nice I mean you all
look nice but like the beige khakis and
yank I give a twirl doing work work work
work work give it a twirl there all
right so let me give the full
introduction Baywatch is out May 25th
yes and you play CJ Parker thank you now
that's that that's the Pam Anderson role
right okay is how much of this is a
comedy all of it it's yeah it's action
comedy yes it's totally meant to be now
do you make fun of Baywatch no no it's
not making fun at all it's sort of
playing into the idea of these are
lifeguards who take themselves really
seriously and the idea that a lifeguard
should be a cushy job and that you know
use a calf runs character sort of comes
in and holds a mirror to what we're
doing saying like hey guys chill out
like get a tan relax
check out the babes and Duane's
character you know it would act like a
Navy Seal and we do too good and they
have their shirts off all the time right
like the rock is looking for an excuse
to take a shirt off
yeah but does it run runs the same way
he's definitely looking for an excuse to
show know that he worked very hard for
those ads but has have you seen a
prettier guy man than Zach ever like
he's pretty right yeah he's very good
looking really good right yeah a great
personality yeah yeah great guy right
and how much slow-motion do we have in
this movie a lot I love Slovakia
it's a four-hour movie
it would only be ten hours have you
spent it up that's exactly hey do you
want to do more of this you accurate yes
yeah yeah alright super fun
what else you going to do like your
other things I'm looking for my next
thing right now you know obviously
Baywatch is a comedy so I think it's fun
to stay in the comedy space have fun
plus it's you know when it's like a
Brooklyn Decker did a movie with Adam
Sandler so it's nice when somebody who's
pretty is also showing their that they
have comedic timing as well like I don't
know do you want to do a dramatic role
here yeah oh you did I mean well I think
I actually started in acting I went to
Georgia I was a theater major there and
then came out to LA and was doing acting
and you know did the co-star than the
guest star than the pilot and the web
series out that whole thing and then the
modeling opportunity just arose and was
like why not write what was the best
show you were on like the best role you
had um well I played a cop on Rizzoli
and Isles check that out okay legal
sexiest costume I've ever worn what was
your do you remember did you have a line
yeah yeah the only one I remember it
just a skit so hung up on it as that's
an apple skiver pan just like a big part
of the investigation like I guess like
somebody clocked someone over to have it
Apple scheming pan because my character
could like recognize that it was like
yeah I know I normally record all of
those I did not record that ones but I
missed that one but yeah yeah you missed
some good content right normally I mean
this doesn't happen normally but when's
the last time a man serenaded you
serenaded saying oh my god it's such an
old old expression serenade does it mean
saying yeah I don't think anyone's ever
sung no man is ever sung for you I don't
think so no has anyone have you guys
ever asked for a girl oh yeah have you
ever been like get over here girl wait
like come on I complimented you and not
throw me a serenade zach is a creepier
another dead guy in the crew someone's
there okay
fritzy would you would you serve be
happy to
better yet because it comes never let
season don't want to freak tickets well
yeah it's fun nice
yeah okay here we go okay all the wings
are my [ __ ] above the cloud the only
way to fly
is on the wings of love on the wings of
love only the two of us together flying
high flying can I get your number you
can leave if you want to okay he was
going to sing creep by Radiohead we
didn't play yeah buddy so like in what
under what circumstance would you use
that like pretty much it's not like okay
now this isn't normally doesn't do it
for his wife yes it hurt all my using
all my songs well you should I mean I
tried then she's like you know you go
throw the garbage at thanks I think
serenading is worth a beautiful it
sounds like are you can stop now
you can see her in Baywatch it hits
theaters May 22 you had no idea what
you're walking into
how big a sports fan are you I mean I
grew up I'm a golfer I think crazy golf
that's kind of nice for which I saw you
at Pebble Beach I know I think we were
supposed to do something I was out there
and I am third hole you made it a very
very long putt you were playing with
Gary woodland yes yeah yeah yeah and I
saw you make the putt you off the green
I think that was the hole but like like
he chipped in everything everybody made
fun everybody made it just shot there
like that you had one from all the way
across the Quran I did but you weren't
intimidated at all not there no super
fun who'd you meet that you hadn't met
before
that's a few celebrities out there yeah
I met everything I'm a Kelly Slater um
he was cool um did you know who Kelly
Slater was yeah I did yeah he actually
used to be on base I was going to say he
was at a lunch alone yeah because that
was funny Kelly
he was the original play was like a
surfer on it yeah um and then I met did
you meet Clint Eastwood I didn't know he
was under the weather right but I know
it came there for the last like I said
that little like celebrity thing on
Wednesdays like Bill Murray you went out
to the par-3 7th yes yes you met Bill
Murray yeah I'm like the worst I don't
know Bernie's I don't know what you
don't know Bill Murray you know I am
Bill Murray but like I say when I grew
up I was like so what do you do and I
love your work
Mark Wahlberg are my mark yeah okay but
you need to get there by nose before you
go out there well I mean they would give
that to you you just go to I didn't know
who was playing the teratogen was fine
well I got sources well I don't have I
don't have a crudo no but if you could
be a pro golfer yeah or doing what
you're doing
honestly after this tournament I was
like not a bad gig it's so fun but if
you had to make your living doing it cuz
it's different if you're just out there
and nothing's attached to it as far as
the money you're gonna make
right right I've never bought
similarities I guess between the two in
the sense that you're sort of both
freelance and you're like don't really
know where your next gig we're next
gonna gig is going to be I'm acting I
mean I I thought actually had to make
that decision in college I was recruited
to Georgetown for golf and then when I
got there took an acting class because
they put all the athletes in there hey
they're in acting you got your hey you
that's all Thank You Suzanne Lipsky for
the only a plastic college how deep is
the pond of Baywatch just in case you
know I'm not able to follow the plot
line up they watch can you help us there
yes so there is no exactly what I have
okay do it I know you've been practicing
do the tag line for big one okay so it's
a group of Life Guards to take
themselves very seriously and because
they do so they're able to pick up on a
underground drug ring that's going to
overtake the beach it's pretty helpful
yeah yeah it's dark some dark material
we're working with will somebody get
nominated for an Academy Award off of it
I would I would be surprised if someone
did you would that they know it I would
be shocked I would feel scorned by the
Academy if we deserve it is there going
to be a sequel to it I hope so yeah
does anybody die yes oh yeah I think
we're like three Jeff you did a shark
attack I mean if it's gotta be a shark
attack come on right okay a shark attack
there's a dis arackliffe yes oh yes but
he does get shot all the time and rest
they shouldn't sail is not real they're
say shouldn't tell you something because
you can't keep a secret can you can you
can you just told us that now he's going
to go the rock gets shot yeah well or
maybe he doesn't maybe I was lying I
don't know you have to go see it
does Zac Efron shoot the wrong hospital
I don't know what to tell you and you
see if this feels like another trick I
would have fallen for that did you talk
to Pam Anderson about this role I didn't
but I didn't know there are cameos Oh
so pammi's in this i don't know you'll
have to go okay now me over dancing I'm
doing so Paley understand damn you know
I don't know who else could be a cameo
dance you're gonna have to go well I
know I'll give you a free ticket I
promise
all these questions will be answered and
I bring the dance as well what about the
red carpet treatment I have Fritzie on
the red carpet and any serenade you as
you walk down the red carpet you want
more than okay
the movie is bayon hits theaters May
25th others so many
plot twists and turns in here it's going
to be incredible a four-hour movie in
slow motion two hours in regular speed
love Baywatch also Sports Illustrated
swimsuit model
how many issues have you been I wouldn't
- yeah yeah you like that yeah it's fine
that's great and then I was shooting the
movie when everyone sighs except you
tell us how the photographer talks to
you when you're doing your sports
they're yours yes you swim too just like
you no no no it's not like that I can
see does creepy things but really
pleased and Genevieve Martin was here a
bear was questions as to when I was
playing the photographer that I went a
little overboard to try to get there
soon as other girls done with what do
they want you they're trying they're
trying to get your best out of you yeah
but they don't say like stupid things do
no no it's like what you imagined it to
be like great great work perfect
gorgeous a lot of everything is gorgeous
like what about the one that was
anticline gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
even more gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous you can see her and they watch
it it's theaters May 25th at receiving
and that one are you sure Fritzie would
you serenade Kelly as we go to break
here the movie is Baywatch head very
white marry one of your baby
may 25th Baywatch give us a little bit
before we go to break their 14 my
friends wonder why call you all the time
what can I say hey I don't feel the need
to give such secrets away back out again
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience